[Música]
[Aplausos]
le voy a contar tres historias tres
ideas la primera historia el cuerpo
tiene memoria una mujer creía que tenía
un ataque al hígado iba al médico cuando
el doctor la revisa se da cuenta que lo
que esa mujer creía que era un ataque al
hígado era en realidad un embarazo de
cinco meses cuando llegó el día del
parto como todo ataque de hígado que de
repente sin embargo es un ser humano
tuvo un nacimiento acordé a ellos y
nació volando pero no porque fuera
rápido sino porque salió literalmente
despedida de ese útero y el doctor tuvo
que agarrarla en el aire literal antes
de caer al piso
cuando tenía nueve meses un juguetito de
plástico vieron esos que no pueden estar
cerca de los bebés bien se quedó
atascado en su garganta dejándola sin
respirar a los segundos desvanecida
despidiendo orina y materia fecal y
líquido por su nariz clínicamente a
punto de morir asfixiada su padre que
estaba distraído cuando logra darse
cuenta que su hija estaba muriendo
introduce dos de sus grandes dedos en la
garganta de la bebé rompiendo el
juguetito de plástico y devolviéndole la
vida
paradójicamente primero se la quitaron
descuidando la iv a los minutos se la
devuelven lastimando la ya que al
retirar el juguetito de plástico
lastimaron su tráquea y laringe
generando después una gran infección en
su garganta que pensaban que iba a ser
muda al mes siguiente su madre por
descuido derramar agua hirviendo sobre
su cuerpo quemándole su brazo izquierdo
al próximo mes
tienen que quitarle un pedazo de músculo
de su brazo derecho porque se le infectó
a una vacuna y antes de cumplir su
primer año de vida su madre es internada
en una clínica psiquiátrica para una
cura de sueño
cuál fue la explicación de sus padres a
todo esto
que la bebé quería jugar con los
juguetes de sus hermanos mayores que
siempre quería estar upa por eso se
quemó y que luego su madre tiene que ser
internada por todas estas cosas que pasó
como irán notando toda la culpa parece
caer sobre una bebé de 11 meses de
aproximadamente 8 kilos
cuando esta bebé creció fue una niña
madura fuerte porque aguantaba todo su
padre decían por ejemplo que yo decidía
qué colegio ir
la niña le preparaba la comida de la
dieta de su mamá cuidaba a su hermano
cuatro años menor y se levantaba a veces
a las cinco de la mañana para hacer
galletitas para vender
sintieron alguna vez que tienen que
hacer cosas para que sus padres se
sientan bien y yo me pregunto cómo puede
una niña ser madura
y se me ocurre una sola respuesta
perdiendo su infancia
pero esta niña seguía jugando hasta que
a sus 8 años el juego sexual de un
abusador llego a su cuerpo
robándole lo poco que le quedaba de niña
y su madre que tenía problemas para
aceptar su existencia
recuerdan ataque de hígado
no le creyó le dijo que eso era un
invento suyo y que no podía ser cierto
seguramente para esa madre fue muy
doloroso
y eligió no creerle dejándola sola y su
padre seguía distraído trabajando
sintieron culpa alguna vez por no ser
mejores hijos
o culpa
por las cosas que les pasaban o cómo se
sentían sus padres
esta niña a los 10 años quedó de cara a
la realidad que su mamá quería ver para
ella sentirse mejor
no pudiendo ver el dolor la confusión y
las secuelas físicas que había en su
hijita
la madre la enmudeció la silencio y la
llenó de confusión desde ese día esa
niña no podía distinguir con claridad
que era real y que era un invento
muchas veces dudaba que si el abuso
sexual que había vivido durante años era
real o un invento como le dijo su madre
pero no no era un invento la equivocada
era su madre porque el miedo la ceguera
y la negación dejaron sola su llega la
dejaron sola en un mundo tan aterrador
como puede ser para una niña de 10 años
donde los adultos que tienen que
cuidarla la lastiman no le creen no la
defienden y la dejan sola pero eso sí
socialmente era una familia hermosa era
un padre exitoso que aparte le había
salvado la vida una madre ama de casa
que pobrecita había sufrido muchas cosas
socialmente una pinturita
seguramente estos padres sintieron que
hicieron lo mejor posible como muchos de
nosotros lo creemos
pero realmente no hay más para hacer
no lo sé esta madre decía que era una
leona que daría la vida por sus hijos
pero fueron sólo palabras porque al
momento de dar la vida por su hija no lo
hizo
porque no estaba dispuesta a asumir su
error no estaba dispuesta a verse a sí
misma porque dar la vida por un hijo
implica vernos a nosotros mismos asumir
que nos equivocamos que descuidamos y
que somos seres humanos
pero como eso duele mucho
muchas veces elegimos negar no escuchar
enojarnos y culpar a otros como estos
padres
y ahora le pregunto a ustedes quién de
ustedes está dispuesto a ver su realidad
para asumirla y poder sanar la
seguramente dirán yo estoy dispuesto
pero saben realmente lo que están
diciendo porque están diciendo estoy
dispuesto a que duela lo que tenga que
doler me atrevo a sentir que me rompo en
mil pedazos para sanar mis cicatrices
y seguramente estén cambiando de opinión
porque los seres humanos queremos sanar
sin que duela queremos ser felices sin
esfuerzo queremos crecer sin crisis y
queremos vivir sin morir y saben todo
eso es imposible
porque somos
lo que hacemos
con lo que hicieron de nosotros
y ahora le pregunto a ustedes
[Música]
que quieren grabar en la memoria de sus
hijos
[Música]
porque les digo algo
hay una sola oportunidad para hacerlo y
es
ahora
[Música]
segunda historia
valorar la vida vivida
podemos cambiar lo que pensamos para
cambiar lo que sentimos
esta frase cuando la niña cumplió 16
años la atravesó de punta a punta
y haciendo honor a sus atributos de
madura decidida y fuerte decidió ponerla
en práctica pero no tenía idea cómo
hacerlo
pero un día enamorada decidió irse de su
casa para vivir a su manera trabajando y
estudiando y su padre el distraído le
dijo si te vas de esta casa es para
nunca más volver
esta jovencita no se dio cuenta
que esas palabras ella luego lo iba a
transformar en el motor que manejaba su
vida nunca más volver nunca más volver
donde la lastimen nunca más volver donde
no le escuchen nunca más volver donde
tenga que aguantar nunca más volver
donde tenga que ser auténtico no puede
ser auténtica
y así lo hizo le costó mucho dolor
muchas desilusiones más abandonos
más de estratos pero nunca se rindió
tuvo que atravesar su propio cementerio
descalza y muchas veces sola
y vivió la peor de las muertes estar
viva y sentirse muerta por dentro
también fue madre
y se sentía viva
hasta que un día cuando su hija tenía
cinco años la pequeña casi muere y se
dio cuenta que muchas veces no había
podido evitar repetir lo que había
aprendido de sus padres y decidió una
vez más girar el timón de su mente para
cambiar su vida y la vida de su hija
[Música]
porque hay algo que esta mujer siempre
tuvo claro
que su vida es lo único que tiene
como ustedes
y les pregunto cómo es sus vidas cómo
son sus vidas
o qué está pasando que están haciendo
con sus vidas
creemos que la vida es injusta o que no
es como tendría que ser o como me
dijeron que iba a ser
pero no tenemos el control de nuestras
vidas
solo podemos decidir qué hacer
con las cosas que nos pasan en nuestras
vidas
y ahí es la gran decisión construirnos o
destruirnos vivir o sobrevivir ustedes
eligen
porque somos lo que hacemos con lo que
hicieron de nosotros
y ahora voy a presentarme
[Música]
soy carla calvi y una vez fui un gran
ataque de hígado y esa adolescente que
le dijeron que si te vas no podías
volver
también soy tanatóloga
sí sí estudio la muerte
tienen la misma cara de mi mamá cuando
se dio cuenta que él está que de hígado
lo paseaba en cochecitos
se los voy a pasar en limpio
hace 18 años que acompaño a niños y
adolescentes a morir
y soy especialista en duelos
y les quiero decir algo la vida sabe la
muerte enseña
tercera historia morir feliz
él era valentín un enano de siete años
acostado en su cama protegido como si
fuera de cristal
él padecía una enfermedad terminal y un
día me preguntó si iba a morir
si mi amor vas a morir le contesté
mirándolo fijo a los ojos y tomándole
sus manitas
bueno yo sabía que eso me iba a pasar
mientras miraba a su alrededor
qué buscas perdiste algo no no no perdí
nada es que todo esto que tengo acá nada
me sirve
para que no te sirven estas cosas para
llevarme las cuando me muera me dijo
gritando me y mirándome como si yo fuera
una tonta y vaya que lo fui
que me puedo llevar
me dijo
me quedé sin palabras
entonces le pregunté con otra pregunta
conteste con otra pregunta que te
gustaría llevarte
oyarce
los besos de mi mamá las cosquillas de
mi papá cuando juego a las cartas con mi
nona y mi traje de hombre araña no mejor
mi traje de hombre araña no
y me quedé sin aliento
un domingo eran las 10 de la mañana y
suena mi celular era la mamá de
valentino que me decía que no se sentía
bien y que él quería verme y así pises
me fui a su encuentro cuando entró a su
cuarto
valentina estaba sentado en su cama
intentando bajar
a dónde vas le pregunte confundida
a hacer lo que me falta para sentirme
más feliz
me contestó
bueno le dije contame así te ayudo y si
para eso tenía que venir para ayudarme a
ser feliz
mientras bajaba de su cama buscaba su
pelota
y me grita vamos salimos al patio
tomó su pelota la puso en el piso
calculó sus movimientos y la patio
y me gritó dale jugar porque yo necesito
hacer dos goles y vos tenés que ser la
arquera
y así fue
fue la peor arquera del mundo y me
hicieron más de 10 goles mientras sus
padres y sus abuelos miraban
felices y con lágrimas en sus ojos
cuando terminamos de jugar valentín se
sentía cansado y se fue a acostar durmió
dos horas y cuando despertó reconocí su
sonrisa
era la última su corazón y el mío
sabíamos que había llegado al momento de
partir
como su primera y última chocolatada
se ve sucio con su madre está agotarse y
su padre lo invadió de cosquillas y
mientras su hermano corría con su nuevo
traje de hombre araña y yo observaba
me acerco para saludarlo porque ya debía
irme
y valentín me abraza
y no me suelta y me dice al oído ayuda a
mi mamá a ser feliz
y su cuerpo se detuvo
así murió en mis brazos
y en ese momento
algo murió en mí también
y como siempre que algo muere algo nuevo
nace yo nací una vez más y en ese
momento decidí que y quien quiero ser en
mi vida gracias al niño más valiente que
conocí valentín
si asumimos que morir es nuestro destino
y de las personas que amamos
vamos a dejar de perder tiempo vida
buscando culpables y sintiendo miedo y
por fin vamos a valorar nuestras vidas y
las vidas vividas de las personas que
mueren
porque la idea
no es vivir para siempre es crear algo
que viva para siempre
y eso es la vida de ustedes y la vida de
las personas que murieron
no le tengan miedo a la muerte porque la
muerte lo único que hace es decirnos
recordarnos que estamos vivos y por todo
esto
te digo agárrate de tu vida armada y
desarmarla las veces que sea necesario
porque de todos modos no saldrás vivo de
eso muchas gracias
[Música]